the main idea about procrastination is
that procrastination is not a
time management problem but it's
emotional management problem
the more you fail the more you have
negative emotions and
then the more you fail in the future
it's like a feedback loop that
reinforces itself
i'm joined by peter ludwig peter welcome
to the show hi
thank you for having me thank you for
being here procrastination
the curse the curse of everyone's
productivity
you're going to guide us through the
murky waters our procrastination today
right
of course i will i love it so let's get
into it
what is procrastination define it for us
wow
is this situation when you know what to
do but you are doing something
very different so basically you know
that you want to
write a new book and you are spending uh
endless amount of
time on social media or you know that
you have
10 emails that are very important but
you are
answering to those that are unimportant
so basically procrastination is a
situation when you know what to do but
you are failing in doing that
not fulfilling the things that you say
that you're going to do
is is such a
huge hole i think and it becomes it can
quite easily become an existential
crisis for a lot of people right because
exactly if you don't have faith in your
own word in the promises that you say
you're going to keep to yourself the
next time you say you're going to do
something you have less faith in the
fact that you're going to do it
exactly and the main idea about
procrastination is that procrastination
is not a time management problem
but it's emotional management problem so
basically
the more you fail the more you have
negative emotions
and then the more you fell in the future
so it's like a feedback loop that
reinforces itself so the more you
procrastinate the more you procrastinate
so
that's why it's so so dangerous and
uh i think that it's it's a
main topic for 21st century basically
everyone is procrastinating
and we see uh that it's it's much worse
than it was
like 10 uh years ago because we have
social media
we are overwhelmed uh at work by so many
emails priorities
so i really believe this that uh to know
how to fight procrastination is a key
skill for
not just to have a successful life but
to have uh
like happy life and calm life
and not to be crazy i love it man
wait where do we where do we start then
we want to not procrastinate we want to
be able to do the things we say that we
are going to do to ourselves
where do we begin looking at
procrastination
yeah uh in my book i have uh
like three chapters and first chapter is
about
motivation how to find long-term
intrinsic motivation
and still i believe that this first
chapter is is the key
to understand why we procrastinate
because uh if we have right motivation
if we truly believe in what we are doing
if we see
meaning in that then it's much easier to
push ourselves
the second chapter is about willpower
but
willpower is just a little helper but
it's not the key for uh procrastination
because if you have strong willpower and
you are pushing yourself to things that
are meaningless to you then at the end
you don't feel
good so first motivation and then
willpower
i know a lot of people that they have
strong willpowers and they are working
on projects they don't procrastinate but
they are working on projects that they
are not meaningful to them
so uh strong willpower can backfire
and so first intrinsic motivation and
then willpower
and the third chapter is about how to
overcome
failures and how to get back on track
when you
uh somehow fail or
if you experience some like
tough uh moments in your life so how to
get back on
on track got you so meaning how do we
find
meaning how do we ensure the things that
we're doing are meaningful no no
no small question yep basically i
i probably read all scientific papers
about purpose at work
about meaning and uh the key to
understand
this topic is to really know your
strengths
and use your strengths doing something
uh
greater than you so not to be just
selfish but ask yourself how you can
use your strengths to do do a
something meaningful to to others how to
improve
uh communities that you are part of how
to
somehow slowly uh improve the world and
so on so using your strengths for others
is is it seems that it's the key for
long-term intrinsic motivation
so basically those people that are just
selfish and
uh if you just want to have uh more
money or if you
want to be uh higher on
a corporate ladder that's not the right
motivation because
then you are still empty because uh you
are just self serving
yourself well a lot of people might say
i'm at university or i'm doing a degree
of some kind or i'm studying
i want this degree sometimes work feels
a little bit like a drain but i want i
want this
law degree this doctor's degree this
marketing degree whatever it might be
um but yet when it's exam time i still
sit down at my desk
and i get distracted i don't do the
things
what's happening there with meaning and
and procrastination how do those two
link in
right uh i do a lot of uh
projects with students too and it's a
huge difference if you are studying just
because of the
of the degree at the end or if you are
studying because you really
want to understand the law and then help
others
or be a good lawyer so
intrinsic motivation is always about a
purpose long-term purpose but extrinsic
motivation is about
goals so and if you read a lot of
motivational books they tell you to set
goals
and i really don't believe in goals
because it seems that if you have a goal
uh then uh okay it motivates you but
when you reach the goal
you experience what is called uh hedonic
adaptation
yeah you get used to that go
very quickly so there was a study and it
seems that
um like the positive emotion after you
uh finish your university or if you get
get a degree
it's only a few few hours
maybe a few days but then you are empty
again
so this is just the pitfall potentially
studied for five years
yeah for a couple of hours of
satisfaction
and in a psychology they call it hedonic
adaptation and it seems that we
uh adapt also on on the biggest
things like if you win a nobel prize or
if you win a
gold olympic medal still the the
happiness
the lifespan of the the the happiness is
one week
or less so i i have a friend and i had a
uh in podcast uh and she she was a gold
olympic
medal winner and what she told me was
that
after she won won the battle then the
next uh
few days were crazy happy and then she
was empty like
and now what i i win the olympics so
what's the next step
so what's the alternative then so what's
the alternative if we're not setting
goals what are we doing
yeah in in my book i uh describe two
kinds of intrinsic motivation
one is intrinsic motivation on goals
and the second is uh interesting
motivation by by
uh by journey focusing on path rather
than the destination
it's the old saying uh uh that the path
is
much more important than the destination
is but it seems that the
recent psychology uh really uh
uncovered that it works like that so
basically
what we want is to uh to be in a state
of flow if you do
if you're doing something and you enjoy
the process then
you reach even more goals if you are
just focusing on goals and you don't
enjoy the process
at the end uh it's much worse so uh
and i have a great example of one of top
hockey players and they made an
interview with him and they asked him
like uh
what is the core of your motivation uh
his name is jeremy ryagar he's one of
top
nhl players and the answer was that his
motivation
is that he loved the process he loved
trainings he loved playing
hockey and if he loves playing hockey at
the end he's
winning medals and it's not about medals
it's about
the journey more than about the
destination so i truly believe in
in this so basically uh if you
love the process you don't procrastinate
doing those things because you
already love the process so that's why
i'm
focusing on a project that
i really enjoy doing and
at the end you don't procrastinate
how do people who perhaps don't have
as much degrees of freedom to change
what they want to do you know
there's everybody's got to do their car
insurance
or file their taxes you know we can't
find meaning in
everything so is the rule to find
meaning where we can
and then is there an alternative
strategy for in the things like the
the taking the bins out the filing the
the taxes what do we do
right right uh i really don't like the
uh the saying like uh do what you love
because if you are telling people do
what you love at the end they don't know
what they love so basically uh i'm
telling
like love what you do so uh for the
in the beginning you should try to find
passion
in things that you are already doing and
there is a lot of science behind that
it's a research from emmy rosnetsky from
yale university
and he calls this process a job crafting
basically it's about to ask yourself
like what is your strengths and how you
can use those strengths
on daily basis or where is the meaning
of your work how you can increase the
meaning so how we can
surveil clients even more how you can do
some
little things that can help your
colleagues
can make them happy and so on and so on
so there's a process how to
uh craft your career craft your your
uh daily working routine and if you
change this mindset about your work at
the end you enjoy
your work much more so even though you
in the beginning
you don't like what you're doing at the
end you can do the same job but
with the different mindset so it's more
about mindset than
uh about the the real work
i understand i think one of the things
that's interesting is
when someone is on
a on a path to a higher purpose for
themselves that might be
be an amazing brother mother father
you know son or daughter to someone it
might be to do with contributing to
their community or it might be becoming
the best athlete that they can
become all of the other things fall in
line to be
in service to that right you know you
have to have
the job that pays the wage so that you
can take
three weeks off a year to go and race um
bicycling
in france or whatever it might be you're
happy to go to work because you're like
look
i feel like my higher calling is this
sport
and this all the the hours at work like
cool i'm just gonna do it i'm gonna get
through it
but you're right like i think a lot of
people struggle with purpose and meaning
because they're just spinning the wheels
they don't actually know what the
reason there is for them doing the thing
and we recently had a couple of uh
podcasts that have touched on this as
well but
explore versus exploit being one of
those paradigms is really important
right in the beginning try
all the different things greg mcewen
from essentialism was on talking about
this
all the different things that you can do
what do i like this no do i like yes no
do i like this yeah
exactly yeah it's okay it's okay and
then eventually you find something that
actually
is the reason that you're here and that
might change over time but
just find something that allows you to
transcend the child yeah so okay i like
i like the
the meaning and and and stuff like that
moving on to willpower what do we know
about willpower how can we utilize
willpower for
reducing our procrastination yeah it
seems that willpower can be trained
in the long term so basically they made
some research
on identical twins and it seems that one
of those twins
if they are raised in different families
can have strong willpower and the second
can
have a very weak willpower so it seems
that it's not
that much inborn basically okay it's
inborn
um for let's say 30 40 percent
but those sixty seventy percent are in
your hand so that's a good news
and the best way how to train uh your
willpower is really to exercise
basically we have one willpower for all
domains so if you do
like 20 push-ups daily uh and if i scan
your brain on
uh fmri uh what we can see is not that
just your muscles are growing
in the long term but also your
prefrontal cortex this part of the brain
that is
uh evolved for willpower so the good
news is
with a regular exercise you can really
improve your willpower and if you have
stronger world power
from from doing exercise then you can
you can use this stronger willpower
at your work in your relationship and so
on so this is the the first way how to
boost your willpower
to exercise daily physical exercise
physical exercise
right and the second uh way how to
improve
your willpower is uh to manage better
your emotions so
mindfulness techniques can really boost
your productivity there was
a scientific study like one or two years
ago
and they linked mindfulness with
willpower with procrastination
and basically the outcome of the study
was that the more you meditate
the stronger your your willpower is so
it's a good news so
to boost your willpower you just need to
spend 10 minutes alone
daily and do some mindfulness techniques
and be able to uh self-regulate
better and be able to uh
overcome some bad emotions with uh
calmness it's interesting
as we're talking about this like a lot
of what
some of the listeners might have
expected as we were talking about how to
overcome procrastination in 2020
it would have been um a bunch of hacks
like oh
this particular use rescue time on your
macbook and keep your phone outside of
your bedroom and do this and do that and
do the other
we're going more high level than that
right right because
that's the only way how to solve
procrastination
i think that procrastination is is like
a
red blinking light and it's telling you
you don't have a right motivation you
don't see purpose at your work
or you you don't have a strong willpower
it's it's it's not about installing a
new app
come on yeah no but
the the fact of the matter is that we
are told
in this gig economy with constant
new courses being released or a new
application or this macbook or whatever
it might be
that that is the tool right that that is
the thing which is going to fix it
and it seems like that's just the icing
on top of the cake
yep i i truly believe that uh
the solution is it's much much deeper
for example there was another
interesting study and the study was
about self-forgiveness
and it it seems that uh if you are able
to forgive yourself
after you fail then you procrastinate
less
and the idea behind that is that
if you are unable to for uh
to do self-forgiveness to then you have
much more negative emotions and it can
backfire again
so sometimes when you fail yo it's not
about failure
that much it's about your mindset about
the failure
and if you are able to forgive yourself
and if you are
fine with that and you are okay i was
able to run
for two weeks and now i failed
just forgive yourself and start again
and
that's why self-forgiveness is one of
those
hacks how to uh decrease your
procrastination
it's very counterintuitive yeah be nice
to yourself so accept
yourself for not achieving the thing you
said you were going to do
right so it's just the opposite what you
should expect
yeah so uh we often think that those
people that they are
uh hard to themselves they procrastinate
less but that's not true
because they are in even worse situation
because they are
hard to themselves but at the end they
have much more negative emotions when
they fail
and that failure pains themselves
like three times more than if you are
able to forgive
you're right i can see i know a ton of
buddies
who will be listening that will
lambast themselves there's
self-flagellation right they'll
they'll whip themselves into wanting to
do more because it's easy to think that
that's the solution i didn't do enough
i need to lean into this even more so
but
what we were talking about at the
beginning i love this idea of having
trust
in your own word like being able to keep
promises to yourself
like if you trust that you're going to
keep a promise to yourself and you break
it
you don't make it better by telling
yourself oh you're such an idiot
like you need to do better next time
what do you do like think about what
happens with a friend
you and a friend get into an argument
they're a dick or you're a dick or
you're both dicks or whatever it might
be
um you say hey man look i'm sorry
let's go for a coffee let's put that
behind us
let's move on exactly yeah yeah and
you you need as a self-esteem to be
productive
so if you are undermining yourself then
at the end
uh you don't trust in yourself and you
have much higher risk to fail again
so i think it's much wiser to be nice to
yourself
yeah i mean jordan peterson be friends
uh treat yourself as if you are someone
you are responsible for
it's such a wonderful worldview but it's
so hard right especially if you
you want to be driven type a personality
you want to do the
work and be as good as you can it's a
slippery slope
to go from um thinking
i am able to accept when i don't meet my
own standards
two i am simply allowing myself to be
lazy i am allowing myself and that line
right
finding where that line is is difficult
yep and
i i have a great tool for that because
uh i told my sir
self this year to only work uh
four four days in a week so i have one
day off
and basically uh in that day
i'm much more productive because i don't
have to be productive
so and for me it's it's it's the best
day in a week because
i don't plan anything so i don't have
meetings i don't have webinars
it's just it's just a free day but i
wake up
then i'm like doing some unimportant
things and then
i'm like okay what's the most important
thing to do now
and basically in in that day i'm working
on
the most important projects and i i love
it
because i don't have to so it's it's
uh just the opposite motivation
to to compare to other days when i have
to if i have a meeting i have to be
there
but uh that day i also can have a
meeting but i really want to have that
meeting
so it's just the opposite mindset and i
really recommend
this uh like tool or
hack to all my clients because
uh it's an investment into your
uh mental health well i mean
isn't it google that gives its employees
20 of their time to work on whatever
they want to do
i think that they used to do that now
they cancel this rule but
uh they had this rule in the beginning
of google
now they don't have this rule anymore
but but
um what are you doing listen to us we're
talking about procrastination
yeah and uh i come up to
this idea when i go on a holiday
i always book one day before a holiday
like holiday before a holiday
and then i book one more day after the
holiday like holiday after holiday
and if you have this like um
[Music]
yeah it works much better because you
are not in
in that uh high level of stress that
tomorrow i have to go
for a location like i i travel quite a
bit or at least i used to
before there was a pandemic
i think i went on like 10 10 or 12
holidays last year
and the number of times where one of my
housemates will say to me
hey man like you all you all set for
tomorrow i'll be like oh dude no
i've got so much to do before i can even
think about leaving tomorrow like i
gotta you do this and then you prep the
podcast and do this on the other
and um you're totally correct like you
so much of our enjoyment in life comes
from the anticipating of things we are
anticipatory beings right
in fact there's some fairly good
research that shows we enjoy the
anticipation of something more than the
thing itself
which is right which is super super
interesting but like i ruined that
i ruined a big chunk of that because i
work
right up until the limit i remember i
remember sometimes
i would get like an early morning flight
and i would pull an
all-nighter before the flight on holiday
and then obviously like the first day of
my holiday was just a complete like
wreck total chaos trying to recover from
the day that allowed me to go on holiday
yep and i have another example of that
is uh japan i go to japan every year for
one month
and i do nothing there it's just my like
empty
empty month i'm not writing a book there
i'm not working on new projects i'm just
there
and it's an investment uh because the
months after i'm back from japan
i'm like three times more productive
because you restart everything in your
brain you restart your willpower again
you you are back uh
in the mood that you you are able to do
things because
your your brain is restarted so
i really recommend to have long holidays
to really
do nothing for three three four weeks
and
at the end uh you are much more
productive so if you
uh sum the whole productivity of the
year
it's bigger altogether even though you
spend one month doing nothing so
uh this is this was the best for my
productivity and for my procrastination
in japan yeah how about people who have
concerns that they might fall out of a
um good habits whilst they're away so
they go
to japan or texas or romania or wherever
it is
for a month and they just they're
getting up whenever they want and
they're not
they're not in the rhythm of training or
working or doing whatever
and they're scared that when they get
back they're not going to have that
routine and it's gonna
they're just gonna all the habits gonna
be out the window yeah
then you have to ask why you want to
have those routines and
often you want to routines because you
don't have willpower to push yourself
to those things and if you spend one
month alone then you have
much stronger willpower so then you
don't need routines that much so
the answer is that after you're back you
are doing everything
much easier and
everything is very easy after being
uh back for from such a long holiday and
the second
very important argument for for this is
that uh i'm entrepreneur i have 35
employees and
i do business for let's say
14 15 years now and for me
this is the definition of the freedom to
be able to spend one month
alone and not to be a slave in your own
company
so i really had to change many things
and
many many many uh processes in my
company
to make the company ready for me to not
be there
and when i moved to the us because uh i
moved to the
two two months to two years ago uh
at the end the company was ready for me
to not to be there
and uh that was the best in my life
because
now i'm very free i can do whatever i
want
and the company works uh without me
so have you read the e-myth the
entrepreneur's myth the book
no no okay so in that they talk about
the fact that
if you have a business or if you're a
business owner
and you can't leave that business
for more than two weeks without
everything breaking
you don't have a business you you just
have
you have a highly leveraged job you'd
love you'd love that book around the
email yeah
it's it's a it's fantastic um so okay
we've got
the fact that we need purpose and
meaning we need to find that we're
getting that through
explore and exploit we're also trying to
connect to a higher purpose
that higher purpose also tends to be
serving other people transcending
ourselves
right the listeners who heard my most
recent episodes with
scott barry kaufman on his book
transcend which is all about maslow's
hierarchy of needs
they'll know that already and after that
we're talking about willpower
we know that willpower ebbs and flows
and it can be trained
that we need to do physical exercise and
what is the second thing that we need to
do
mindfulness mindfulness to regulate your
emotions
cool because as i said in the beginning
procrastination is emotional problem
rather than time management problem i
love it um before we move on from
willpower what side of the fence do you
sit
on about whether or not you get
willpower depletion through the day or
not
yeah basically i believe in depletion
because
uh i my experience is whenever i'm tired
it's much
more difficult to push myself to do
things and
whenever i'm tired i procrastinate uh
much more and uh it's easier to me to
drink beers and so on so i believe in
depletion during the day
but i truly believe that you can
overcome the depletion with small rests
during the day so basically sometimes
i'm my
i'm tired and then i have a big toe for
let's say 500 people and at the end of
the talk
i have new energy and uh
i'm able to restart everything and
i truly believe that working on projects
that are meaningful
uh are not draining your energy but they
give they give you the energy so that's
why
uh if you procrastinate at the end you
are
empty but if you are working on
meaningful projects at the end you
have even more energy than at the
beginning that's the problem i have
when i do this podcast because i'm often
recording with people in america
and that that recording time tends to be
about six or seven pm at night
and then i've got to try and wind down
and i'm going to bed at like
10 o'clock and my mind's still buzzing
yeah exactly about all of the cool stuff
we've just talked about
so yeah i i get that a lot the reason
that i wanted to ask
some of the listeners who haven't delved
into the
ongoing internet battle that is is ego
depletion
true or is it not there does seem to be
this constant like
first roy baumeister does a study and
then you say yes and then there's
someone else who says no and then it's
yes and no
and it's just like like trends with is
it cool to have skinny jeans or loop
jeans
or is it called wear like a sleeveless
t-shirt or a t-shirt with sleeves
i mean yeah but i truly believe that
both sides are right
because uh sometimes it's uh depleting
but sometimes not
so i i believe that uh if you read all
those arguments
it's not like uh black or white i think
that the truth is
again somewhere in the middle yeah so
it's possibly be both yeah the the
funniest
uh the funniest argument that i've heard
so far for ego depletion is ego
depletion
exists if you believe it exists
have you heard that one yeah yeah yeah
yeah you like that so i'm like it's
getting like that yeah
[ __ ] like what do i need to can i
unlearn can i unlearn the word ego
depletion
um so yeah i don't know about okay so
that's
two chapters down third chapter uh third
chapter
was about uh handling failure and
i truly believe in some uh
like deep experiences and
i want to explain you more in detail
what those experiences are
uh i have two examples that i
experienced something that is called
near death experience
first was that i was like 19 years old
and i was playing basketball
and i had some like brain of
um kind of paralysis and after a few
hours
right side of my my body was completely
paralyzed
and it was the first situation in my
life that i was
uh experiencing the situation when you
really think that you can die and [ __ ]
it was
[ __ ] scary but
it really changed my my my values it was
very humbling experience
so i was in the hospital
i was thinking that that's the end of my
life but
at the end i survived that after few
days without any side
side harm side effects so basically it
was the best
uh experience because since then i'm
thinking
slightly differently about uh what is
meaningful
or what's not so for example during the
pandemic
i only saw one of film on my netflix
only one because i really don't want to
waste my time
what did you watch what was the film oh
it was serious about donald trump
and uh
and after the beginning of the pandemic
i switched everything and i was working
on the project masks for all
to help as many people as possible to
wear face masks
and so on so i switched my focus from
procrastination to face mask
from one day to another so i spent like
three weeks in a row
every day like 12 hours uh doing on that
project
so and it was very meaningful so i i was
not procrastinating i remember when i
i've got a number
uh a telephone number for one lady that
is
one of top executives from o and i
called
her directly because i didn't
procrastinate because i was in like
okay if i procrastinate there are people
dying
so it was the most fulfilling
period in my life the beginning of the
pandemic so good
i i i watched um i'm gonna give you a
a potential second thing to watch on
netflix during the
during the pandemic and the guys from
vox
have done a series called explained and
it's mini
mini documentaries around about 20
minutes long and they've done one on the
corona virus and it's three parts
the first part explains how a virus
works it talks about sort of the biology
of what viruses are
um and then the second one talks about
the implications i think more nationally
and internationally
and then the final one talks about what
vaccines are and how vaccines work
and dude when you look i think there's
about 70
to 100 vaccines that are the front
runners and there's maybe two or three
that are really at the
the um highest likelihood of this and
when you
see the epidemiologists and the
virologists and the vaccine creators
in their labs these people are living
eating
sleeping everything in their laboratory
they're not they're not having problems
with procrastination
right now yeah because they're doing
something meaningful and they're using
their strengths
so it's just interconnected what was the
second what was the second story
yeah uh the second story was that uh it
was 2015 and i had a flight from
amsterdam to prague
and after the take off after like 15
minutes after the
takeoff our right engine blew up and
there was fire
and yeah you really don't want to
experience that during your flight but i
experienced something
uh terrible and uh we had to
uh perform emergency landing so
the thing that they are telling you in
the beginning like uh put your
head in front between your knees and so
on
i really experienced that oh my gosh so
and it was terrible because i was
sitting just next to the engine so
the the guy uh um
next to me told me like look there is
fire and i was like no i don't want to
see that
don't remind me mate all right it took
us around like 15-20 minutes to uh
to to land and those were like
the longest 15-20 minutes in my life
london an airport
oh yeah we we get back to the uh
amsterdam to amsterdam airport
but but only with one engine and uh
the airplane was shaking and it was very
noisy
amsterdam to prague will be a small
plane it's not a big 747
right no it was just the the
standard size plane like the normal one
yeah
but it was quite scary and when we
landed a few people were crying there
and we were hugging each other and the
pilot
uh he he went outside of his cockpit and
he shake the hand with all passengers
and it was very strong experience and
again if you experience something like
that
at the end uh it's very humbling
since then i'm like thinking okay like
uh
how to really invest my time wisely what
are those
main things to do and i really don't
wanna i won't
waste my time with social media for
example because it's it's
mostly meaningless you're just consuming
things but you are not creating
and so on so uh i think that the
coronavirus
is similar to those two uh
stories from my life because uh we were
all in this similar situation we were
in danger of pandemic and uh i want
the coronavirus to be similar to
those two uh near death experiences of
myself
for the whole society and i truly
believe that we can change because the
the old
world had many problems yeah so i truly
believe that we need some changes in
societies
around the world like we are many
societies are divided
many people are working on
projects that they don't believe so
there is a huge lack of meaning at work
and kindness is is not a virtue for
for many people so i really believe that
this situation can change
uh things man i i couldn't agree more
there's a ton of
quotes and and thinkers that have been
referring to recently one of them being
naval ravicant and he says play stupid
games win stupid prizes
and that touches on the social media
thing like what's the point what's the
prize for always checking your instagram
three times a day like you don't get
anything for that you just satisfy
yourself
there's this quote from uh jean-paul
sartre here that i've got
it is our duty to risk the easy and
common place for the unique and great
to work toward our full potential in the
face of all obstacles including
ourselves
to take responsibility for our life and
what we make of it
ultimately no matter what we do or say
or believe
there will always be a great many who
disagree or judge or ridicule or become
upset by our decisions
but it is of essential importance that
we try as often as possible
to ensure that among these people
ourself is not one of them
that's it man that's it incredible yeah
i love it and
i truly believe that we are all on the
same boat because
we are all global citizens and uh
i have experience living in europe in
the us
in in asia and japan and what i feel is
that we are all the same we have
the same instagrams we have the similar
struggles the virus basically
was everywhere so now we know that we
are on the same boat
so why not to cooperate more why not to
be more
collaborative as uh as a mankind
because we are divided by so many stupid
things
[Laughter]
man again it just it's so
counter to i think innately what we feel
we should do
because maybe a little bit of social
norms you see these guys crushing it
always working hard type a mentality me
with my rolex me with my fast car me
with my big hands
um but every single person
that i know that is well respected
within the field of evolutionary
psychology
or cognitive psychology or leadership or
organizational psych everything everyone
says
that the best way to improve your life
is to improve other people's lives
and it's right there's not some big
[ __ ] conspiracy going on here
there's not like some masonic lodge
hiding with big cloaks over their heads
in a darkened room with a big pentagram
on the floor saying we need to get
everyone to think that they need to work
with each other so it makes it easier
for everyone else that's not the way it
is
all of you guys everyone that is an
expert in this field is converging
on the same outcome because
there is truth in it yeah and i truly
believe that we have only one
enemy and that's our ego because uh
if you have a big ego like if you are
egoistic and you if you think about
yourself
then it's very difficult for you to help
others because you are only thinking
about yourself
so humbleness in my world
is uh the key uh antidote for
for the ego so basically those uh near
death experiences
or those difficult moments uh those
humbling experiences
then help you to help others more
because
then you understand that the world isn't
it's not about
yourself it's more about others because
if you are
if if you die well
the life continues without you so that's
why you should help others
and improve the society because it uh
you live your life
after in those people that's your legacy
right
it's your legacy and it's your
immortality
if if you are self selfless so
being selfish selfish is is
very very uh how to describe it
like being selfish is is um
not that twice let's say okay
how do you um how do you have how do you
hold in reality at the same time
the fact that humbleness is a virtue
which helps you to remove the ego which
is bad for you
but you need to be able to have pride in
doing things well to encourage you to
continue to do things well how do you
hold those two things together
i truly believe that it's not one or
another but you can have
both you can be like healthy egoistic
like focusing on others but being able
to say no
being able to have your private
room that you are able to
uh have your time for yourself and so on
so basically
if you are too selfless for example
those mothers that they are only
investing their time in in their kids
and they are
uh they don't have their uh hobbies
anymore and so on they're
not that good mothers at the end so
being
like health is selfish means that you
invest in your
health you invest your time in in in
your sleep
and at the end if you are healthy
selfish you have energy to help
others even more so and it's all about
to have a courage to say no
because you you have to uh have
a time for yourself i understand to help
others
okay so talk to us about how near-death
experiences and being humble relates to
failure and procrastination
oh i truly believe that everyone
experienced something similar
everyone experienced failure everyone
experienced
some problems in their relationships and
so on and
being able to like overcome those
problems
in terms of uh like changing your
mindset
about those failures is a is a key for
boosting your self-esteem for the future
and then you procrastinate less so
basically what i advise
is to do a simple
exercise like to take a blank piece of
paper
and uh write down the graph of your
happiness during your your life so for
example when you
were when you was a kid it was nice then
then studies it was bad it was good
again and so on so
basically have your like a lifetime
uh graph of your happiness and
if you are somewhere down those are
those moments
that uh are the best
in terms of uh if you recognize what
this situation
gave you for example in terms of your
values for example if you ask yourself
like
how that situation shaped your values
for example my near that experience
uh the first one shaped my values
because since then i don't want to waste
my time so i appreciate time much
much more than before so even though it
was like
very unpleasant experience at the end
it changed my life in a positive manner
in a positive way
so and i truly believe that everyone has
those uh situations and if you ask
yourself how this situation
uh helped shape your values or
what was the positive outcome of that
then uh
you can gather some uh some
wisdom for the future and you have much
more positive emotions and then you
procrastinate less because you know that
even though you fail
then you gain something uh positive so
you don't you are not afraid about
failure that much
does that mean that traumatic
experiences are better learning
opportunities than successful
experiences yeah it is
there there is a huge meta analysis from
2009
about post-traumatic growth and it seems
that
if you have a traumatic event then you
can have post-traumatic
ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder or
you can have post-traumatic growth
and the the key or the difference
between those two people
is really the mindset so basically there
are many examples of uh survival
of concentration camps and at the end
they
lived to their 90s hundreds and they
wrote
many books and they lived a many full
filthy lives but there are
it's also examples of many people that
after uh
they uh liberated those camps they
committed suicide
so and basically uh i truly believe that
not the situation but our mindset about
the situation shapes
the future for us so even though i
survived too near that experiences
i think that uh i'm very happy
that i experienced those two events even
though it was
so so scary i know i said this at the
very beginning of the coronavirus that
it's one of the few things that can
unite us as a species right
exactly it doesn't even rain everywhere
on the planet at the same time but i
know what it feels like to be in
lockdown the same as someone in italy
the same as someone in
america the same as someone in brazil or
wuhan you know i know what i don't have
the perfect
but i i'm united i'm reading um toby ord
his book his new book the precipice and
it's uh he's from the future of
humanity's institute and it's all about
existential risk
it's like make no mistake about this we
are a thin
veneer of surviving on top of what is
everything is trying to kill us
from natural risks to anthropo
anthropologic anthrop
whatever it is that risk to the to
future risks that are going to come from
fire weapons from artificial general
intelligence whatever it might be
and he this is this guy has written
a 500 page 400 page book on it
from the premier existential risk
department
in the world and he puts our chance of
surviving the next 100 years at 50
percent
why like that that is a reason to live
your life that is a reason to try and
find the most meaning to try and be the
best person that you can be
and again like when you reframe that and
you realize
i've spent uh 150 hours during lockdown
watching netflix movies that i didn't
even like
it it does shine quite a harsh light
onto that and that's not me saying i
don't do it like i waste my time just as
much as anyone but you know what i mean
no i i have a great example like when i
started to do movement masks for all
with the first video uh
it was the most fulfilling experience in
my life because
slowly after a few days people started
to wear face masks outside
here in prague and then i
took my good friend and she was studying
uh in l.a she's she's a
director and we made a uh english video
and the video went viral now uh the
campaign masks for all has
reached more than 1.2 billion so
we basically made a video and that was
your video that was your idea
it was well my and her video
and it was featured in cnn bbc
in the main media around the world and
then it was shared by by a few uh
few american uh senators
and a few candidates on a u.s president
and politicians around the world but
from both
sides both parties for example ivanka
trump shared
the the picture that she she issuing her
own face masks
and uh it was incredibly
positive uh moment of my life when i saw
that we are all
united in front of the virus
and it was so strong to me because uh
now we have volunteers everywhere
around the world basically we have more
than 1000 volunteers in new zealand for
example
and uh the solution for the pandemic was
to really
wear face masks and now there is a lot
of new scientific evidence that it
really works
so and it started with my simple video
and then another video and then it went
viral and now 70 plus countries have
uh masks mandatory and we have evidence
that it's really started with the video
like you've managed to change the world
what is what a thing to do okay so i
want to i want to kind of
bookend what we know about
procrastination we've given ourselves a
nice framework there
let's say someone's listening and they
just
keep procrastinating they've got a bunch
of tasks that they've got to get done
maybe they don't quite have the degrees
of freedom to be able to
not do them they can't get rid of them
to find meaning
you're sitting down now to start to do
the things that you have to do
what would you say or what are some of
the things that those people can do in
terms of actual takeaway tactics that
will actually move the needle for them
well do 20 push-ups daily
basically do exercise on daily basis
because it really
can boost your willpower ask yourself
what is the real reason why you are
doing those things so what is the
purpose
so basically ask the question why why
are you doing those things
and how you can uh improve those things
that you are doing
in terms of a greater meaning
so how can you add some small details
that can help your clients or your
colleagues
even more and then
ask what are your strengths and how you
can improve those
those strengths because uh if you
already believe in what you are doing
and if you believe that you are skilled
in those domains you enjoy the process
even more
and focus on the process more than uh
the destination so goals are not
important because we are getting used to
them because of the hedonic adaptation
so try to enjoy the process more and
try to enjoy the every minute and uh
i call this healthy perfectionism
because uh
that i have this concept from japan so
whatever you do try to do it as
as as good as possible and
if you are focused on details you enjoy
the process even more so
that's cool i notice i noticed today you
haven't mentioned
anything about next actions about next
physical actions or about breaking
large tasks down into their next
iterative step
is there a reason for that no i i have
this in my book too but
i think it's it's uh too obvious
so i wanted to discuss some non uh
intuitive uh ideas
i mean for the people who don't see it
as obvious would you be able to explain
the concept of using a next action
okay for example when i was uh writing
the book uh
in the beginning i told myself well uh
write a chapter
so i had in my to-do plan
write a chapter and write a chapter is a
huge
uh task so i had a very negative emotion
towards that task but if you
uh like cut the the big thing
into smaller parts then it's much easier
so for example if you told uh tell
yourself to write
two paragraphs daily it's much easier
than to write a whole chapter so
basically this is a key hat how to
overcome procrastination so
if you procrastinate something just cut
the task in the middle or
uh divide the task into three smaller
tasks and then
it's much easier because as i said
procrastination is emotional
problems so you have to really decrease
the negative emotion
uh the aversion against the task and if
you divide the task then you have a
smaller negative emotion i like that i
like that a lot i think
the the marrying of the big overarching
meaning based conceptual stuff with
breaking things down so for instance the
next action's one of them i know that
you have
uh on your website you talk about um a
lot of the time people might not
continue a task because they don't
actually know what to do next
right like what what should i do and you
talk about i think it's um
go and do some research or ask someone
for advice are those the two
[Music]
i mean the number of times that people
sit down to try and do a task
and they procrastinate on it because
they don't actually know how to do the
thing that they're trying to do
now obviously if you don't know how to
do the thing you're trying to do you're
not going to do the thing that you're
trying to do right
exactly yeah so that's why i love some
like visual plans
like mind maps you can you can uh for
example if you are starting a new
project
i highly recommend to start with the
mind map because then you know
like what to do next for example uh when
i was writing the book i had a mind map
for
each chapter and when i was about to
write i already had a map
and it told me like today you should
write about
uh willpower for example and
to have a visual plan helps you to know
what to do
next so it's it's like a real map if you
are lost in
a city uh without map you are confused
but if you have a map then you know what
to do next
so uh i highly recommend you to have
mind maps for every project
that you are working on yeah i'm someone
who naturally doesn't plan
a whole lot um which i know yeah is is
shocking
um but the more that i've trained myself
to be able to do it
i it it changes it's such a game changer
and i think
um previously i had a resistance to
planning
because i thought this time that i'm
spending planning could be spent doing
i don't need to do the plan i can just
start doing it this is all wasted time
why would i spend two hours planning
something i can get two hours of working
what you don't realize is that that time
at the beginning makes such a difference
you're like
10 times more efficient 100 times more
efficiently exactly yeah
100 percent right with the writing it's
it's like that because if you sit and uh
tell yourself okay now right you don't
know what to write
if you have a good plan and if you have
a like mind map for
almost every paragraph of the book then
it's much easier to write
you just write what and you know what to
write so um
like if you spend some time with
planning at the end
as you say you are sometimes more
productive yeah probably
peter it's that's awesome man anything
else to say any final notes that we
haven't covered today any bits that
people need to know about
procrastination
well uh i really want
people to really rethink their lives
in era of the virus and i
truly uh and highly recommend
people to be
more humble after the crisis so
humbleness
should be the um outcome of the uh
crisis
so that was the main uh
idea for me for today i guess
man i think um well anyone that's
leaving
the last few months anyone that's
leaving 2020
and feeling like it's time to have it to
build an ego up
like you just haven't existed in the
same reality that the rest of us have
how can you see this as anything other
than
wow mortality and humanity are so
tenuous and so delicate and i
i and you know it does
say a lot for the way that people are
developing that i'm speaking to my
neighbors more as i do a morning walk
now and people are coming up and
they seem to be i haven't seen road rage
like do you remember road rage i haven't
seen road rage in like four months
there's no road rage everyone's uh this
guy's having a bad time this is
challenging
there's more understanding more empathy
right so
maybe maybe you're right maybe that's
what's going to happen
or perhaps people's memories are going
to be short and it's going to take
mother nature to fire another shot
across our bow
for us to realize that we need to get
our egos in check
right yeah so probably this crisis can
help us
and if not we need another crisis so
that's fine
well i'll tell you what if we if we
haven't fixed it you can just order us
another crisis
amazon amazon probably have a couple of
crisis that you can just buy so go and
get yourself one up there
um where can people get your book peter
and what else should they check out what
do you want to plug
uh yeah it's it's very easy our domain
is procrastination.com
so you can remember it easily and it's
i guess everywhere it's in 18 languages
now so we have japanese translation
korean translation
many uh european languages so you can
get uh
the book in your favorite language
and then what about you are you on are
you on social media people want to check
you out yeah of course it's at p
e t p-e-t-r-l-u-d-w-i-g so my
name and surname uh i'm
mostly on linkedin and instagram i don't
like facebook that much because my
timeline is full of crazy political uh
facebook facebook facebook's been never
been as bad as it has now you know what
the fight the the final fatality
of covet 19 is facebook news feeds
that's what it is right
right and they really paid the best
uh etiologies around the world to make
the
timeline more addictive to you so
basically it's your
uh like a personal tabloid for you
and it's all about your emotions so they
know
what uh makes you crazy so um so that's
why my
uh timeline's full of trump trump trump
trump trump
i get you look man peter it's been it's
been great i hope that it's hoped
helped a lot of people to get over their
procrastination uh everything that we've
spoken about be linked in the show notes
below if you've got any questions
comments or feedback you know where to
get them
at chris will x or find peter online and
give him give him some hassle as well
dude thank you so much and
congratulations on your amazing
social campaign for the uh for the masks
and chris thank you so much for this
interview i really enjoyed that and next
time we should do that
uh in person because yeah i mean
i like to do everything online so yeah
we can do it
so thank you for having me and uh
listeners take care
and stay safe of course